how many times have you had that feeling
of impending doom as you watch your
mobile phone battery drain away
knowing full well you don't have a
charger well i had a moment like that on
a train and it got me thinking about my
own emotional battery
and the fact that it needs attention i
started to think how do i recharge
myself
and stop myself from being overwhelmed
and tipping into emotional burnout
so what exactly is emotional burnout the
term was first used by herbert
freudenberger
in a research paper in 1974
he himself had many major life
challenges including fleeing persecution
in germany
setting up a whole new life in the u.s
learning a new language and
studying for his degree at night classes
whilst working in a factory
he described emotional burnout as a
state of mental and physical exhaustion
caused by one's professional life and he
described many different phases
including a compulsion to prove oneself
these days we describe emotional burnout
as excessive
and prolonged stress leaving us feeling
unable to cope with life's challenges
and crucially these stresses come from
many different areas of our lives
it could be financial our relationships
moving home
losing our job or exams any major life
change or events
so how do we keep an eye on our
emotional battery and prevent ourselves
from getting overwhelmed
and tipping into emotional burnout be a
compassionate listener to yourself when
someone experiences a physical knock we
tell them to take it easy and we fully
expect them to take
time to recover well it's the same for
emotional knocks
so start checking with yourself daily
how are you feeling
agitated tired stressed run down
we very rarely take the time to really
check in with how we're feeling
and when we do we often get stuck in our
heads and analyze things
but it's really important to listen to
what u.s philosopher and psychologist
eugene gedlin called
our felt senses having butterflies in
our tummy when we're feeling nervous
is an example of this but we very rarely
stop reflect and really tune into how
we're feeling
think about a time when someone you know
well really listened to you
how did that feel be a good and
compassionate listener to yourself
set aside time about 20 minutes to
really stop
tune in and listen to how you're feeling
without judgment
are you the type of person who can
usually cope with stressful and
challenging situations at work
but are struggling at this time well
that might be a clue that one of your
emotional buckets
is low on reserve think of your reserves
like this
you have a work bucket and a home bucket
if one of those gets low
but the other one is well supplied
you'll probably be able to cope
but if they're both low and you have no
reserves to draw on
that's when problems can occur when one
area of our lives is undergoing a
battering
other areas can help recharge focusing
on an area that's going really well and
squeezing as much good feeling out of
that as possible
can really help strong relationships are
really important for building resilience
so is exercise and doing things that you
enjoy
so you can think of these as charges
don't be like i used to and look for a
charger when you're already in the red
zone
build habits and routine into your daily
life
it might be going for coffee with a
friend listening to a podcast watching
your favorite comedy
anything that you enjoy make time for
that and prioritize it like it matters
because it does babies are often put to
sleep with a lullaby
and research has shown that actually
listening to relaxing music before
bedtime
can help us all get more sleep and
better quality sleep
music impacts our parasympathetic
nervous system which is
all about relaxation so do whatever you
can to get the best sleep possible
the american sleep association found
that adults who sleep less than eight
hours a night report higher stress
levels
than those that get enough sleep when we
don't have enough sleep
or poor quality sleep this impacts our
mood our focus
our concentration and our ability to
deal with challenges
and no one wants that so now you might
just understand why that moment on my
train journey helped me with my mental
and emotional well-being
and hopefully it will mean you'll start
to check in with your own emotional
battery
and prioritize it just as much as you
prioritize your mobile phone on
you